we are joined by Ross pruden who's taken
time out of his day to talk to us about
this goodbye promised release of our so
this is we just launched it today and
this is something that sort of been
marinating in our minds for the last
year not necessarily to release it under
the IndieGoGo but to just experiment
with with releasing goodbye promise on a
crowdfunding platform initially we were
actually thinking Kickstarter and then
you know Karen had the premonition to
say you know what I really want to
release done in indy gogo and so and
then we started to see new things there
but Ross you you're seeing it live for
the first time with a few other people
today and you immediately back that you
gave us a very hefty contribution you
know you went way above the things out
the dollar mark the two dollar mark and
that that's really super grateful for
that I mean hello so you obviously see
something here that we're doing that is
really registering with you yea big yeah
can we just maybe hear something yeah
dude so much like your thoughts yeah so
uh one of the first things i look at
whenever i'm looking at a crowdfunding
campaign is what the one dollar perk is
first of all if there's one dollar poke
if there's no perk then that's an
indicator that people don't really know
what they're going I mean to be blunt
about it because a one dollar per is a
very very cheap indicator it's a cheap
way to offer people way to buy in and
find out what's going on with your
project so at a bare minimum you should
be offering it just to say you know get
our updates for all in one dollar
doesn't cost very much but when you
truly offer something that doesn't cost
anything for you to send from one dollar
you're really maximizing the internet
because the Internet just loves to be
able to distribute things easily for
free so if you're charging one dollar
for something that effectively is is
free for you to make you're actually
making a prof
margin of a dollar now whenever I go to
a crowd funding program a platform like
Kickstarter you know that's great if
you're if you're trying to raise
thousand 10,000 20,000 but no one raises
a million dollars on Kickstarter they'd
be crazy unless they have a really
amazing project so most of the time
people go to Kickstarter because it's
it's an all or nothing and you get
people riled up and they're really
excited and they you know in the last
day or two all mine comes comes in which
is great in a sense but it is an
all-or-nothing campaign so i usually
don't look at IndieGoGo simply because
of that reason but there are some cases
where IndieGoGo really excels and this
project is absolutely one of them I
looked at it that were the first things
I saw was wow we're trying to raise a
million dollars that's awesome because
even if they don't it's IndieGoGo they
get to keep whatever at whatever they
have raised and their first perk is one
dollar and you get to rent the film for
knowledge that's that's a great bargain
in and of itself so that's the first
thing I looked at and then I realized
because most the you know everyone gets
greedy they think oh yeah we have to
offer 10 25 50 dollar perks nothing
lower than 10 and I don't see any reason
why you have to do that you can offer a
one dollar pork and a two dollar
perfectly like you've offered and it can
be very successful if your objective is
to make some of the money back that it
took you to make this film and expand
your fanbase you can't do any better
than a dollar it's I mean apart from
free but one dollar is effectively free
so when I saw this I immediately said to
myself these people get it they
understand how to leverage the internet
for themselves and that I mean I believe
in the rewarding people who get it and
so that's why that's why I donated so
much the only thing that I'm that I
really wanted to see on this was what if
I if I wanted to buy the film or up my
pledge later on in campaign if I can see
like a DVD or some other kind of
scarcity that I can't get any other way
I you know then it would be awesome so
anyway that's that's those are mine
shull dots and I like that one thing
about the DVD is of course the cost to
make them what if they were to do maybe
behind-the-scenes footage for an
additional amount do you think that
would be of interest or is that sort of
what do you think sure okay I mean it's
hard to tell what that kind of what the
price point for that is people usually
by behind-the-scenes footage bundled
with the DVS they couldn't expect that
but I mean if it's if I like the film if
I if I watch it instantly for a dollar
then yeah i mean i would i would
probably up my pledge to if I were just
donating a dollar or two dollars and I
thought oh well I can get to see some of
the behind-the-scenes footage that's
probably worth another couple of dollars
or something sure okay sure but not you
know 50 or 60 or so it depends on how
Abbott a fan argue you know people
really love your film they love
everything about it they'll pay a lot
more for it so no you know one thing we
want to kind of do with this
conversation Ross is really you know
Karen I do so much of interviewing other
people you know in this case you know
one thing we're going to be doing with
with our release of goodbye promise is
you know turning to other people that
have expertise such as yourself and in
this area you know in and out of the
film world turn to you as mentors and
really you know turn over the reins a
little bit to you so I at any point if
you have questions if like if you have
thoughts at a turn in your head that you
want to turn on us and maybe we can
answer we factor that to be part of this
conversation so I just wanted to throw
that out there to address the DVD thing
I guess you know really at this point in
time you know I guess I guess what we're
looking at here is the number the number
one thing is we wanted to get the film
out to people immediately you know we
didn't you know it's such a small film
when we when we shot it we did it we
didn't have a production budget all we
had was a camera and some passionate
people actors that want to be involved
and sort of see if we could see if we
capture this feeling of what it's like
to be you know
pursuing this dream in LA day in day out
you know so you know that that's kind of
what we're doing and um wow I've totally
lost my father already out i'll even our
own it good okay this might be diverting
it a little bit since you said you do
have our campaign up on your screen do
you think the message is clear do you
think there's anything we're leaving out
is it overkill with the photos should we
maybe have more photos we you know uh no
i think actually on all it's a good
campaign it's succinctly f it it has
absolutely think you have to have
photographs and you have to have a video
the only thing that's really missing
honestly are additional tears i would
add more tears more perks and they don't
I mean you know Here I am talking about
more perks I've got like 17 or 18 perks
on mine but I mean having like I've
donated 25 dollars because I believe in
you guys and I've followed you guys for
so long and in part that's I'm probably
an outlier in that respect because there
this is not for people like me this is
for people who never heard about this
film necessarily so the second degree is
going to be like I'm the first degree of
separation second degree of separation
is going to look at this campaign and
they're going to say sure what the heck
there are 12 dollars that's that's not
that much and i know someone else a like
a friend of mine he's already rented it
but then what happens if they really
like it and they want to donate more up
their pledge or they want to get some
sort of souvenir from you because i
think that's really what it is i mean
i'll give you a perfect example i got
them I got the DVD of what is it that
movie about the 911 knockers I came up
the name of it by Green Street greenery
rocks and balls Negros I'm sorry was it
Paul Greengrass yeah that's it that's
the one yeah amazing film I've seen it
one time but I felt was the
kind of thing that I had to have a DVD
of and I've watched it one time and it's
one of those films that you can really
only watch one time or maybe two times
because it's so depressing but it's such
a moving experience that you feel like
oh my gosh I have to own I have to own a
piece of that so offering people a
chance to have some sort of a souvenir
like a touch soon when they say this was
a great experience and I want something
to remember it by or use it as a
conversation point like have you seen
goodbye promise you're an actor you
really love this you know yeah I pay for
the rental but there's nothing that I
can show you its online but I came over
the link you know what I mean so it's
it's that kind of thing I probably add
some more perks if I were in your shoes
but all in all I think it's a great
campaign oh well great well I'm
wondering though what types of perks
though because you know sometimes you
see oh hey you get a mug or you get a
mouse pad or or you get a t-shirt and in
it sounds nice in theory but we know
from marketing t-shirts Oh film courage
it's not a huge moneymaker and then you
hear someone like Troy Duffy who makes
his living from t-shirts yeah I'm doc
saying so I don't we haven't definitely
crossed over to that line what's a
rewarding perk that well matter I think
this is one of the most frustrating
things for people who don't really
understand crowdfunding and understand
the new way of selling things is that
it's not going to be a t-shirt for
everyone right it's not a
one-size-fits-all kind of perk you look
back to what the topic is about what
what it is that you're selling and what
you're selling here is very clearly a
life in the day of an actor or you know
the the trials and tribulations of what
it means to go to cattle calls and to
face rejection and what do you do at the
end of it so I always look at what the
project is what what tangible things or
something that is truly unique to the
story that you can offer someone that
they could not really get from anyone
else so for example and I'm just talking
off the top my hands here but you know
you could send a thank you card but the
cut thank you card would be
the in the in the format of cattle call
sheet right so something that actors can
relate to and that people who maybe are
not even actors get a glimpse of what
it's like to feel like like going to an
audition or you send them an audition
tape reason you know all these things
that an actor and experience would
experience that experience is reflected
in some of the souvenirs of the perks I
don't know if that really answers your
question but I'm just kind of riffing
here thank you you know that let me sort
of address let me address the higher
parks you know because because I I do
fully agree with you um that it'd be
great to have those higher tier perks
you know I guess where we're coming from
with with this campaign is you know
obviously we've set sort of the
impossible goal you know we don't
necessarily expect to come anywhere near
that goal but at the same time we didn't
want to cap it off you know um you know
we believe our audience is somewhere
between 100 and a million and I've said
already that it it's probably cool it's
probably it's probably closer to my it's
probably close to 100 we know that but
but you know a planet is going to grow
like if you put a plant in a jar it's
going to grow to the size of the jar you
know with the internet we have we had
the ability we don't know how far that
can spread so we didn't want to cap it
you know we just wanted to open it up
and let it be free so that that
certainly goes into what we're doing
here and we wanted to make this as
simple for us as it is for for people to
see the film so it was very important
that you know I mean we're essentially
using IndieGoGo as sort of like to
receive payment and we're granting
people access to the film and we're not
we just had a conversation with Gregory
bang and he said like don't be cagey
with your work and we didn't want to be
cagey we wanted like like right now if
you want to see the movie for free you
can see the movie for free we can't stop
you um you know any go-go's it's
different from Kickstarter in the sense
that you can't do private updates so
when we crafted the idea the idea was
you know pay paid through the side and
then go to and then it would only be
available to the people
are supporting it because it would be
hidden in the update section which is
only accessible to those who have
contributed but at this point in time
and ego go a setup where it's public
they don't have private updates so we
have this sort of just say okay we're
going to go ahead and do this anyway
which right to some degree is kind of
scary what we wanted to do that but
really we just wanna we wanted to
automate it we didn't want to be stuck
where we're gonna have to be fulfilling
orders from now like for the next six
months you know we wanted this is to
just have it so that you're very simply
getting getting the film that's what it
is we're not trying to over complicate
it you know and we're just trying to
reach as many people as possible we
realized we probably not going to reach
a million once again you don't know what
with the power their net what could
happen so we doesn't live we let it be
and we'll just reach people one by one
that that's the plan so weird ended yeah
we're just trying to automate it that's
all it just it gets it gets really sort
of like you know recently I was able to
sit down us and listen to adam chap Nick
speak he had a he had a presentation in
Santa Monica I'm at the apple store and
he spoke about the angry video game nerd
who had a very successful campaign on
IndieGoGo and he had some of these
higher tier rewards and here is months
later or may I don't if he's fulfill
them all by now but his campaign was was
far more successful they thought it was
going to be I think of maybe I'm just I
might have the numbers wrong here I
think was a seventy five thousand dollar
goal and I think he raised over two
hundred thousand dollars and so there
were a lot of people there are a lot of
people that contribute at those higher
levels but then it demanded more of his
time so instead of getting our time into
your work you end up putting more time
into fulfillment and that's that's I you
know that's why what we decided to do
instead is we decided let's try it
instead of having like individual
rewards for backers I don't know if you
see at the bottom of the page but it
sits in its baby stages right now but we
have we have group incentives so gasps
saw that you know so we just I like a we
can afford to send out a tweet for the
first 228
people and then if we happen to reach
500 will have stuff that we can share
with everybody that we can put out
everybody that doesn't necessarily
demand the amount of time that it would
take to fulfill individual rewards right
right yeah yeah so I noticed two
different campaigns they were both
extremely successful and they had
totally different approaches to
merchandise fulfillment one of them was
of course the amanda palmer campaign and
she raised 1.1 1.2 million and all told
she's keeping about forty thousand
dollars which doesn't sound like where
does all that money go well first of all
she had a lot of debt that she had to
wipe off was something like two hundred
twenty-five thousand dollars of debt
then she had to pay her lawyers and her
agent and her manager and then she had
pert fulfillment costs and I mean you
know and of course Kickstarter takes
their cut and son takes their cut and
then pretty soon it's you know a very
small amount of money really that she's
left with and she goes you know I'm okay
with that because it's part of a larger
plan to make money when I go in tour
because her objective isn't to make
money from the Kickstarter her objective
is to release an album and build her
fanbase to really solidify it so that
when she goes on tour people are craving
that chance to see her in concert so as
part of a larger plan it made a lot of
sense but then there's the other end of
the spectrum which is see Frank's
Kickstarter which he did a really
interesting post-mortem on it and his
approach was more like what you're
talking about where you don't want to
offer something that is too expensive to
ship to produce getting turns for
produce it ship it it's just if you're
spending seventy to ninety percent of
what it takes to actually pay for the
thing what's the point because he was
trying to raise money for his TV show so
he was very he clamped down really hard
on making sure that
if someone paid ten dollars that it only
cost him a dollar or two to make it and
ship it so I mean they're different you
know wasn't he wasn't going on tour like
Amanda Palmer was it was a totally
different situation I mean in your case
the movies already made all right so
it's a sunk cost if you can make any
money off of it that's great so yeah I
don't know if that really answers your
questions I didn't know that about
Amanda Palmer this oh yeah that's really
staggering Wow yeah but she's walking
with forty thousand dollars after all
its butt off you just would not expect
that at all well learn a whole strategy
is not about making money it's about
making fans and the fans stronger more
avid fan you have I mean I'm a huge fan
of you guys that's why that's why I gave
you twenty five dollars could even
though I didn't need to because I'm like
I support these guys they've done given
so much the community they deserve to
have some sort of payback and I feel
like I'm getting you know that you guys
are getting stiffed and I got the good
in the morning is I got a chance to
donate to people that I really wanted to
that's that's what your show if you did
your show is doing such a great step in
the direction of building a strong fan
kit so thank you no thank you Ron says
that really means a lot you know and you
know one thing I mean you kind of bring
up the the price point there or maybe we
can touch on the price point no and this
is something that Karen I've gone back
and forth with was I you know what what
should be that price point you know I've
been really adamant that like I want a
dollar price point you know because I
you know and you know we're hearing that
quite a bit in terms of just having
things be frictionless you know and of
course you know we could check you know
we could always have it a higher price
point whatever three four dollars five
dollars and a lot of people you know
maybe like you that are the stalwart
supporters will be like absolutely will
pay that you know I'm certainly
concerned with once we get beyond that
that inner circle you know those
post-print friends and family you know
the visionaries that jump on early once
you get beyond that and then you're kind
of then you're kind of stuck and it's
like the people that don't know you and
there
looking at and you're like well you know
four or five dollars can be a lot to
some other people especially that
connection doesn't exist so exactly um
but at the same time Karen's like I
don't want to just charge a dollar she's
like I want to do what you want to speak
on that a little bit oh no I'm you know
five we just thought maybe there should
be I was thinking more 299 but i think
our agreement was was too after the
initial hundred people to jump on so
we'll see how that works but i like you
know the idea of additional person and
you can add them as their campaign goes
along so um which is quite we're not
sure what that might be well it has to
be something compelling enough and I
like what you're saying about having it
be something about an actress journey
mm-hmm but you know justjust also to a
Gregory Bane was saying the same light
as you are just moving that needle along
just the way Amanda Palmer not to see
the dollar amount but just to see more
eyeballs you know fans people that care
about what you do so ya know if you look
at from that point yeah yeah she had
over 20 sorry she had over 23,000 donors
Wow and I think just over 4,300 if I
remember correctly or were simply one
dollar backers Wow but for one dollar
backers you got access you got access to
all the content of her all of her entire
album before anyone else right so I mean
it's not you're not just paying for her
whole album which is like 12 or 13 15
songs you're paying for access to the
album which is I think a huge
distinction because once it's done I
think I mean she may put it up on iTunes
she probably almost definitely will but
she doesn't really care tech points it's
more about getting those people in and
seeing what she does and then up selling
them to someone else and I myself i'm
not a huge Amanda Palmer fan or I didn't
used to be but when I looked at that oh
my gosh one dollar that's that's nothing
i mean i'll throw what's a dollar that's
nothing so you buy in i bought in for
one dollar initially I was about to and
then I looked
the $25 CD it was like a limited edition
CD won't be made after this campaign in
life okay why not twenty-five dollars so
i put in twenty-five dollars and then
later in the campaign I up did to 125
because she was offering an art book
that meant amazing the whole campaign
she's talking about this art book and
she's a really good artist too so I feel
like wow I mean I would never never
spend $125 on an art book but I feel
like this is a limited edition
opportunity and I get to brag about it
when it's done dudes I got this one you
know I got the southern $25 art book
it's awesome and nobody else has this
except for me you know and all the
people who bought it with me so I don't
think that that can be underestimated
there's a huge potential I went from one
dollar to 25 to 125 so yeah that's great
great no oh no I mean this is thought
not only is it just her work and and and
but it's the legacy of the campaign I
mean just in passing yesterday I heard
two people talking about it so yeah I
think and that will carry people over
because whenever crowdfunding comes up
oh well did you know about him into
Palmer and then she's got more people
going to what she does you know even
though the campaign's over so she has
that residual effect of campaign yeah
you'll appreciate this I heard I heard
someone say whenever you're crawling
around to a producer to have them read
your your screenplay be really nice the
receptionist because one day they may
run the studio right so it's the one
dollar you know the one dollar people
may end up becoming your most avid fans
you just don't know ya gotta take a
long-term you know that yeah I mean you
know just I mean we're very mean this is
the first day and this is going to be a
short campaign to this it's just like a
31-day campaign I believe we got it up
mid morning at like four in the morning
last night it's just you know after a
long day and not getting home too late
at night and then just working all night
to launch it but but we see some
interesting interesting things happening
already I believe we've had 16
contributors so far
and we do have you know we have the one
dollar you know price point which is for
the early birds and it's limited edition
it's a hundred people get it for a
dollar right now and then the other
standard perk is two dollars and we're
finding that a lot of people so far at
least our lectin just to go for two
dollars or more which is really
encouraging to see that and that's
that's what we were kind of wondering
I'm coming into this like what would
that what would that situation be and
another takeaway so far as we had a you
know we originally raised money on
Kickstarter to help with post-production
costs and so far a few of those people
have come over and then they've thrown
in another buck or two which is really
really cool to see you know thank you no
I mean obviously you know obviously yeah
you say it'd be great to have like a
bundle or something um you know for you
no more to give people but you know
right now we're just we're just we just
think this is the best way for us to
reach people with with this project yeah
cool and Ross do you think that the 30
31 days is is adequate time you think it
should have been longer uh no I think
that's that seems to be what a lot of
people out there do I mean it's uh
there's no real deadline for it I'm add
that if your if your goal is to raise a
million dollars then you know 30 days
may be too short but I think your goal
really is to get as much money as you
can within 30 days I think that's
totally fine but again it's not about
the money it's really just about seeing
your fans are now I don't know that I
actually know that much about IndieGoGo
do you get emails of the people that
that contribute leave them it's
interesting i don't know if i don't know
if they're actually sending us the
actual email addresses i have to take a
closer look is it you know when it comes
in to our gmail it's kind of like you
have to click on the thing where it says
like you know just play images or
whatever it's kind of like hitting the
way it comes in but it you know we are
receiving the notifications like it's
all grouped together in gmail so like I
said we have like 16 emails that are all
grouped together right now I don't know
if the actual email just is there which
would which was certainly something that
we were hoping for because it would be
great to have you know the email access
chair I guess we'll have a clearer idea
very soon we'll take a closer look and
see you know we do have the ability to
message people within the indigo world
platform so I sick they're signed up we
can but I don't know if we can and if we
update that obviously is going to go to
everyone that's contributed right that
all that all sort of serve as the email
I don't know if we have to actually
email address i'm not short okay and in
terms of updates can you think of some
fun things that we could do that just
that sort of think outside the box type
of updates um you know the the blooper
reel that you did for Christmas this
still has me chuckling so I don't know
if something that you can whip together
but you know so far as so far as fun
perks you know there's a really fun
program from off the iphone called i
think it's called frame agra fur or
can't member it's basically time lapse
it's really easy and fun to do
time-lapse photography and one of the
perks that i wanted to do for my
campaign was if i had a certain number
of people i don't know I've forgotten
what my plan was but if I had certain
number of people within a certain amount
of time I would do a time lapse shoot of
me writing one of the stories in the
campaign which I think would be you
could do like a serious version and a
totally silly version with them back to
back it got really funny so I don't know
I mean it's you know what what are some
of the fun things that you got I'm not
asking you I'm just this is food for
thought what are some of the fun things
that you do in in in doing this film and
doing this Kickstarter that you've
really been telling stories about to
each other and all your friends like you
wouldn't believe what happened that
that's usually great fodder for for for
perks I can't really think of anything
in particular right the second but you
know it's just about it's about telling
stories it's always a really good place
to start yeah I like that that
time lapse idea i'm wondering with the
comedy you think it's appropriate even
though it's more of a drama just to
bring some light hardness into it so
it's not to sort of depressing i think
you think that's okay um we're all gosh
it's project dependent right so people
who were people who are interested in
this particular project I mean you have
to ask yourself what exactly is it that
they're watching this film for and
that's not always a really easy question
to answer I mean I personally I come
from an acting background so I
immediately relate to a lot of this
stuff already and imparted to other
reason why I stopped being an actor
because it's so hard but and this is
something that Adam Chad Nick actually
brought to my attention if you if you
put your if you put your project in
larger movement in some sort of social
direction then your film has real legs
because in this case the actors go
through probably depression they go
through self-confidence issues i mean
it's it's really hard being an actor and
that might be part of what you could
offer is some sort of connection some
sort of affiliation with an actor's
group or maybe you know suicide
prevention maybe that's extremely get
the idea is that it can be outreach to a
sector that's somewhat related to this
topic that can then say hey you know if
it's if you find it difficult to have
self confidence in your life then this
might be a film that you can relate to
as that work as it relates to tears and
perks ah tricky i mean i guess that mmm
i'd have to think about it I'd have to
think about it like I say it's project
specific so it's really you got to know
a lot about the project and getting the
minds of the people in the audience no
that's good that's great
Thank You Russ you know what I want to
touch on is you know maybe we can
continue to learn more because do we
understand it right that you're getting
ready to launch your own crowdfunding
campaign tomorrow yeah it's tomorrow
right Marv all right ten a.m. yeah I am
so so tell us about some of the work
you've been doing behind the scenes and
what is this project you're getting
ready to launch so about a year ago less
than a year ago I was at story world in
in San Francisco which is the first
annual conference for transmedia people
so lots of different kinds of people and
I I had a meeting with friend of mine it
was a very good author and we were
trying to come up with ways for authors
to make money and not have to worry
about piracy and you know competitive
markets and the internet when everything
can be copied so and it was very similar
to what i did with you guys i SAT there
and as I was sitting there I felt this
overwhelming urge to say man he's such a
good writer I would love it if he wrote
a story just for me so that's the origin
of this whole thing I thought what do I
have my pocket and reached around i
pulled out ten dollars and i say i'll
pay you ten dollars for 100 word story
and i wrote on the ten-dollar bill and I
gave it to him so from that I realized
ten dollars works down to about one dime
per word so that's the idea for this
campaign is that okay maybe if maybe if
I offer my fans my friends my followers
my family an option to pay ten dollars
per 100 word story it's not that much
but the idea is to create as to
commission a story and then once it's
paid for I don't have to worry about
licensing issues or piracy I set it set
it loose into the wild public domain for
ever and ever and i want you to copy it
i want you to share it i want you to
remix it sell it I don't care the point
is I want to build the fans and once i
had that that that 100 that list of 100
donors
right a bonus story that's time to the
number of donors in the campaign so if I
get ten thousand donors I'll write a
10,000 word bonus story so if it really
goes viral and I hope of course we all
have our projects go viral but if this
one does and I get a hundred thousand
donors I'll have to write a hundred
thousand word novel but I doping in the
public domain so that's the idea is to
really leverage it really let the
internet copy things so and one gets you
all the stories that's the best part of
all know you know leading up to today
you know behind the scenes that has been
stressful for care and I you know just
just trying to get things ready and it
just it just gets to a point where it's
just like you've had the idea for so
long and you just have to say you know
what we're going to do this even this is
even if this is the most insane idea
ever we're just we're just going to
launch it and just follow through and
just kind of hold it or that that sort
of promise we made to ourselves can
maybe you speak on some of the fear the
fear and the expectations that you have
because you're you're getting ready to
do this tomorrow so can you teach oh
yeah about your mentality it's it's
terrifying it's absolutely terrifying
you're putting your ass on the line and
you're hoping that people don't laugh
their butts off at you now I mean it's
it's like being an actor you walk in you
think okay I'm going to do my best and I
really hope they don't laugh as the
doors closing behind me yeah so yeah and
I'm as i was telling someone today i'm a
huge numbers guy i analyze things over
and over and over again and you know I
realize you just have to step you know
acknowledge that it's there step to the
side and keep going and it's you know
you got pull the trigger at some point
and another way to look at this at least
for me for this particular project is
that it's one big experiment and if it
fails it's not the end of the world you
know I don't I don't have everything
riding on this in part I don't have to
worry about not making goal because then
that means I don't have to do anything
writing so you know it's i'm i'm being
paid on the front end instead of on the
back end so but yeah it's it is a
terrifying experience because you're you
do the best that you possibly can and
then you just cross your fingers and
over doesn't slow news so you have a set
of sorts o this campaign is on
kickstarter is that right tomorrow it
will be as up tomorrow morning it's on
my arms are ten o'clock and how long is
the campaign it's going to go until the
fourteenth of sep tember i think let me
just double check the dates so we have
like parallel efforts here we're doing
this time yeah exactly and do you have a
video that you're doing I'm sorry do you
have a video Ross that you're doing with
this campaign or yeah I thought I shot
it up here in my my drives my driveway
and had to wait for cars to stop going
by and planes and birds and stuff but
yeah yeah I shot a video for it which I
think no no crowdfunding campaign can
get away with without a good video
because it helps you really connect with
your audience you know I I hadn't I
hadn't seen a cousin for years and she
sent an email to me of pictures from her
wedding which I didn't even know that
she'd gotten I heard that actually that
she got married and when I saw the
photos i had this just overwhelming urge
to pick up the phone and call her I
didn't have her phone number so I sent
her an email and it really just drove
point them you know the drove the point
home then you have to have a visual
reference people respond to visual input
whether it's just a picture but a video
is great because they can late to you
they understand you know it's facial
movements so it's really matters that is
a big deal and how much effort did you
put into the video um probably the
writing I probably put all told about
eight or nine hours of writing you know
writing cutting writing cutting starting
over writing cutting over and over and
over and over and then the shooting of
it I mean oh my god I can't even tell
you how many times I probably do tin
takes until I finally went with the last
day because it was all
just one take and it wasn't perfect but
it was one take and it was genuine you
know started out with a really rigid
like I'm going to read get every
everything in there and then I realized
people don't want that they want
authenticity you know whenever we watch
American Idol or acting or anything
people respond to someone who's being
genuine they respond authenticity they
want the real thing that's why we why we
love drama we want something real and
the more real it is the more powerful it
is so yeah I spent a long time probably
a week I would say all told and did you
have anyone helping you like frame the
shot I mean are you literally setting up
the camera and then running your you
know pressing record running in front
and doing it that way your honor yeah
but that's me well even worse I had to
be like okay we're in the kids way
when's my wife way okay there's ever
went away from me Wow yeah yeah
definitely and then just finding time
where I'm not falling asleep to do all
the stuff that I need to do yeah that
was something I mean we literally pushed
our you know cuz karen was like you know
David we need we need to shoot this
pitch video we need to get this cone and
it's just you know our life has been as
you can imagine you know we just have a
lot going on every day and it's so like
just barely being able to keep up with
everything we're doing it's like just
because of that we ended up sort of
procrastinating just pushing the pitch
video into the last couple days it was
like really just getting that thing in
down under the wire and you know and
that's the main thing we're going for we
were wrong for sincerity we wanted this
sort of you know sure authenticity have
a little visitor they're very cute cutie
of 20 come on you committing to so I'd
like to introduce Zoe she's my agent oh
hi Zoe and and then penny over here I'm
you can see her that's my manager okay
great value team Ross yeah this is so
anyway yeah we stand up stand up on me I
can I can see Zoe's like she'sshe's see
sizing us up
sorry I don't go shader yeah hi sell you
these girls are upstairs watching on TV
that's all right well I guess we should
probably call on into it it's like you
know this is my this is my other
co-production right here okay all right
Ross thank you for taking care of my own
action um so so just give us the finally
just give us information on dying word
what you know what's the full rundown so
dime word is funding as funding public
domain literature modern no public
domain literature it's one dollar to buy
all the stories it's ten dollars to
Commission your any story sweetie Shh
just a second and you can follow us on
twitter at dime word and that's where
would be posting love the information
but yeah just do a search tomorrow for
dime word or my name on Kickstarter and
it will probably come up you'll know
it's me brian it's awesome they
appreciate we appreciate you thank you
thank you so much i'm oh thank you yeah
good luck i hope you guys clear million
in 30 days thank you the awesome we'll
give it our best shot Thank You Ross
right thank you alright thank you and
yes good bye bye